TERRITORIAL GAINS HAVE BEEN
MINIMAL.
FRED PLEITGEN, CNN, UKRAINE.
>>> WELL, SCOTT McLEAN IS ON THE
GROUND IN LVIV.
SCOTT, YOU'RE LIVE ON CNN.
WHAT WAS TARGETED?
>> Reporter: BECKY, WE HAD A
CHANCE TO GO OUT TO THAT AREA A
COUPLE HOURS AFTER THE BOMBS
ACTUALLY FELL, AND WE MANAGED TO
GET A VANTAGE POINT ABOVE THE
AIRPORT RUNWAY IN LVIV.
THIS IS IN THE WESTERN PART OF
THE CITY.
THIS IS A WHOEK POINT INTO THE
CITY WHERE THEY HAD A CHECKPOINT
NEARBY.
WE WERE ABLE TO SEE SMOKE COMING
FROM A BUILDING JUST BEYOND THAT
RUNWAY.
ACCORDING TO LOCAL OFFICIALS,
THAT IS AN AIRCRAFT REPAIR
FACILITY.
IT IS NOT CLEAR WHETHER THAT WAS
THE INTENDED RUSSIAN TARGET OR
NOT.
BUT IT IS NOT UNCOMMON OR IT
HASN'T BEEN LATELY FOR THE
RUSSIANS TO TARGET AIRPORTS,
ESPECIALLY IN THE WESTERN PART
OF THE COUNTRY.
CITIES LIKE.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME THE BOMBS
HAVE FALLEN WITHIN THE LVIV CITY
LIMITS, BUT THIS CITY HAS BEEN
PREPARING FOR WAR FOR WEEKS.
THIS IS THE KIND OF LESSON THAT
FEW PEOPLE WANT TO HAVE TO TEACH
AND FEWER WANT TO HAVE TO USE IN
REAL LIFE.
IT'S BASIC FIRST AID FOR A
COMMUNITY COMING TO GRIPS WITH
THE REALITY OF WAR.
>> Translator: I'M AFRAID,
BECAUSE WE ARE NOT PREPARED.
I AM NOT A PROFESSIONAL SOLDIER,
BUT I UNDERSTAND IT IS BETTER TO
MEET THE ENEMY BEING PREPARED
AND WITH THE RIGHT SKILLS.
>> Reporter: DR. ROBERT IS AN
AMERICAN WAR VETERAN WORKING
WITH THE GLOBAL SURGICAL AND
MEDICAL SUPPORT GROUP BRINGING
MEDICS DOCTORS AND SURGEONS TO
UKRAINE TO TRAIN CIVILIANS.
IT SEEMS FUN NOW, BUT THE
SCENARIOS MAY SOON BECOME
REALITY.
CIVILIAN TRAINING HELD IN A
LOCAL GYM ATTRACTS ENGINEERS,
TEACHERS, DANCERS, ALL KINDS OF
PROFESSIONS AND AGE GROUPS,
INCLUDING HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
SUDDENLY FORCED BY THE WAR TO
PUT THEIR OWN PLANS ON HOLD.
>> I DON'T UNDERSTAND AND KNOW
WHEN I WILL IN FUTURE STUDY,
BECAUSE NOW IT'S HARD TIME.
AND I DON'T KNOW WHAT CAN BE
TOMORROW.
>> Reporter: THEY ARE TEACHING
PEOPLE BATTLEFIELD SURVIVAL
SKILLS LIKE HOW TO APPLY A TCOUD
YOUR HONOR KIT.
HE IS ALSO TRAINING DOCTORS TO
PREPARE FOR THE TYPE OF WOUNDS
RARELY SEEN IN CIVILIANS DURING
PEACETIME.
>> IF YOU'RE IN NEW YORK CITY OR
LONDON OR A BIG CITY, MOST OF
THE INJURIES ARE BLUNT.
A CAR ACCIDENT OR A FALL OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
MOST OF THE INJURIES ON THE
BATTLE FIELD ARE PENETRATING
WOUNDS THAT MIGHT INJURE A MAJOR
VESSEL.
>> Reporter: ALL WITH A FRACTION
OF THE RESOURCES.
>> DO WHAT YOU CAN WITH WHAT
YOU'VE GOT.
>> Reporter: IN MANY AREAS,
MEDICAL FACILITIES ARE GETTING
HARDER TO COME BY AND SUPPLIES.
AND IN THE WORST HIT AREAS MANY
HOSPITALS ARE NOW OPERATING IN
BASEMENTS WITH ONLY FLASHLIGHTS
TO AVOID ATTRACTING RUSSIAN
BOMBS.
THIS IS A DERMATOLOGIST FROM
WESTERN UKRAINE.
ONE OF DOZENS OF MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS SHARPENING THEIR
SKILLS FOR BATTLE.
>> Translator: IN NORMAL LIFE,
DERMATOLOGISTS DO NOT PROVIDE
FIRST AID, DO NOT DO TOURNIQUETS
AND PUNCTURES.
>> Reporter: SHE'S PLANNING TO
JOIN THE MILITARY.
>> I PLAN TO GO TO THE WAR
FRONT.
MY CLOSE FRIENDS ARE IN WAR WAR,
AND I WANT TO BE THERE, TOO.
>> Reporter: SPEAKING OF PUTTING
THINGS ON HOLD.
THE AMERICANS TEACHING THE FIRST
AID COURSES TO BOTH ORDINARY
CIVILIANS AND TO DOCTORS, MEDICS
AND SURGEONS, THEY HAVE PUT
THEIR LIVES ON HOLD IN THE
UNITED STATES.
THEIR JOBS, THEIR WIVES, THEIR
KIDS, TO COME HERE FOR SOME, FOR
SOME INDEFINITE PERIOD OF TIME
OUT OF A SENSE OF DUTY.
ONE OF THE THINGS TO MENTION
QUICKLY AND THAT'S THAT LVIV HAS
BECOME A SAFE HAVEN FOR
ACCORDING TO CITY OFFICIALS,
SOME 200,000 PLUS PEOPLE.
AND WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING AT HERE
IS A DEMONSTRATION OF EACH ONE
OF THESE STROLLERS OR BUGGIES
REPRESENTS ONE CHILD THAT'S BEEN
KILLED SINCE THIS CONFLICT
BEGAN.
SINCE THIS INVASION BEGAN.
AND SO THE ORGANIZERS WHO PUT
THIS TOGETHER IN SUPPORT OF
DISPLACED PEOPLE SAY THAT THEY
WOULD VERY MUCH LIKE TO KEEP IT
THAT WAY.
THE GOVERNOR OF THIS AREA SAID
THIS ATTACK ON LVIV SHOWS THAT
THE RUSSIANS HOLD NOTHING
SACRED, NOT WOMEN, NOT CHILDREN,
NOT DISPLACED PEOPLE EITHER.
>> WHAT A POWERF